just give me one minute - this is
usually the present show where people
need my glasses are steaming up a little
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by comedian David Cross
he's finishing up the making America
great again torn if you missed it don't
worry cuz there's a Netflix special
August 5th making America great again
David welcome to the show
thank you for having me my wife is not
happy that I'm doing this she's no no
she has tried numerous times to persuade
me to not do it well let me ask you this
why'd you decide to do it
I kind of like a challenge I like
experiencing things that are very
extreme and you know at least once so
you know I watched like four or five of
these clips you can see people it stops
them in the tracks and I know going into
this it's not gonna be pleasant could be
good 24 hours and just ass on fire just
literally flames like a blue butane you
know you could cut steel with what's
going to happen eventually so let's uh
let's try it out
I got a compliment you first of all on
your production value it's fantastic do
you mean it no I mean these wings look
like the kind of wings you get at
Madison Square Garden in the early 70s
yeah just up behind the curtains I know
what a great experience it is to be on
our show the making American great tour
your first time on the road and what six
years yeah it was a little under six but
rounded up to six what did you miss most
about being on the road
wouldn't you miss least the thing I miss
most was getting to do sets where you go
to people Bob loaded Kirk and I would do
these little mini tours and then they
would always be just like East Coast
cities West Coast cities and you really
feel kind of guilty people like we drove
seven hours you know this is the closest
you're coming and and it really is nice
to be able to go to two people the thing
that I miss that I that I missed the
least about it is then it happened a
couple times we get depressed and kind
of spiral into this little depression
where it's usually in the middle of the
tour you're on your you know 12th show
in a row and you really truly don't know
what town you're in what time zone
you're in and there's nothing to do that
can get really oppressive you know
jerking off watching 24-hour news
whatever not not in that order not
simultaneously oh yeah definitely yeah
yeah but not exactly in that order do
y'all have toothpicks by any chance
that's all right I'll wait till the end
I it's my shitty British teeth or
catching all this stuff I know that
you're a big fan of the Sky Mall so much
stupid [ __ ] in it I love it I went oh
Jesus it it it went bankrupt but you can
still order online okay good I want to
show you some items and just react to
them tell me if you think you'd buy tell
them if you think it should have been
invented not invented just whatever I
just want to show you some that I think
a you might have these out of SkyMall oh
all the Marla's SkyMall okay a replica
of the Oval Office desk if that's the
president's where's like the cubby hole
for the girl though where does it see
Monica yeah yeah where would she well
they all had one don't be not just Bill
Clinton
looking at a [ __ ] for 5415 dollars
what do you think of that money well
spent for sure especially if you're
doing kind of a Mission Impossible thing
where you've kidnapped somebody and you
know they come to and you're trying to
convince them they're in a room like
this you know and try and commit some
that you're the president that they've
been asleep for you know 16 years and
probably cheap for that kind of thing
outside of that use then no they have a
bunch ads racist I don't know what
you're showing me but that's [ __ ]
racist a giant male silverback gorilla
statue with a thousand seven hundred and
seven dollars white cheerleaders it is
weird but in frame at this and after
harambe come on man have a hearts got
pleases when you're thumbing through do
you ever see those cuz sometimes they'll
have like an elephant that weighs 800
pounds and there's like 15 feet tall
that you're just supposed to put in your
yard I guess yeah well I love my
favorite is the the creepy zombie thing
that's like the grapes like who like
Sasquatch looking behind a tree and
stuff it's a heated hoodie with a power
bank on sale for 144 dollars that's
that's one way to do it but you could
also if you were really cold uh put
something over the hoodie like a coat or
something like that
if only they vented something yeah do
you think like who buys these things are
like who never what about this when you
do an international leg of a tour are
there certain towns that seem to like
David Cross more than others people had
told me oh they're more reserved in
Europe especially in Scandinavia and the
last four shows I did were in fall in
Scandinavia and I've been told like by
number of people yeah Scandinavian
audiences are very reserved you know
they'll love you but they'll respect you
and they're not gonna whatever and they
were great they were the best shows I
had the throughout the whole thing they
were like it was very raucous and those
last three were fantastic
pain is good louisiana-style so your
movie hits it really Lampoon's
modern-day celebrity culture what do you
think the consequences are of
celebrating the anti-intellectual the
way that we seem to do in 2016 you have
a narcissistic kind of self-centered
nothing we didn't have that already but
I think it just it facilitates that
negative part of you know society at the
risk of sounding like a grandpa I feel
like there really is that kind of like
put your [ __ ] phones down and you're
looking at some beautiful pictures of
nature or you know this thing and you're
in it just put it down and observe you
know and that's kind of depressing when
you see a lot of that
oh sure dork
mm-hmm mm-hmm how do you make a hot tub
glad you asked that's good right
yeah it's got almost got like a tomato
easing we wanted it to be kind of hot so
we have it hot but then we undercut it
with like a pineapple citrus blend so it
kind of Trojan it horses in that heat I
lights up your mouth and we got you a
bottle so you can take one home a
hedonist exclusive they distribute it
and then homeboys hot sauce oh there's
your name on there right on my name god
I like this a lot as far as my question
you know mr. show is considered by many
to be you know one of the best sketch
comedy shows that's ever been made and I
don't know if you're aware of this but
it has kind of a second life because
every once in a while you'll see these
little articles pop up it's like yeah
the the Ru pretty bad I'm sorry to
interrupt no I want you to finish it
then mr. show comes true like yeah
particular feature yeah yeah there's all
these sketches that you guys did and
then they've somehow think their theory
list is like 14 or 15 at this point I
have a couple a handful that I want to
bounce off of you and I just want to
know it were you surprised to see that
idea sort of come to life do you
remember the Marilyn Manson pizza party
and mozzarella employees are fun
fellas extroverts who make their own
rules and then there's this thing alice
cooper's up in theirs town i've been
there in denver how do you think the
women have to kind of wear a cross
between like sexy referee or umpire
outfits but with like Alice Cooper I
like if it's quickly cleared it's a very
specific fetish how surprised on a scale
from one to ten four point six eight
four point six eight good baby massages
remember yet the crazy died yes I have I
when I was in London working on Todd
mirga the first time for a second year
was there I got a photo of it you know
Dada Dada Dada and baby decide when we
wrote that that was just made us all
laugh that absurd idea of like you know
Jay Johnston massaging a baby and people
like yes it's wonderful for the baby
it's very good for its development how
crazy and absurd is that an infant on a
scale from one to ten how surprised were
you on that one six point zero seven
okay you had that sketch about the
government blowing up the moon America
can should must and will blow up the
moon and then I don't know if you saw
but they kind of uncovered that there's
this Cold War mission yeah to nuke the
moon and everything that I've read about
it that was just to show how big our
balls are like I thinking that was the
reason that was a ten on the shot today
that was a ridiculous comedy bit that
was crazy the other ones I can sort of
get but that one is insane this is High
River rogue and this is where the game
starts I went rogue uh and Boulder they
opened up for leftovers and this seems
to be such a heated and divisive
election year is someone who's done
political commentary and satire for
decades is there something unique about
now we're getting in a hut that's what
I'm saying okay how does making people
laugh in this election year compared to
making people laugh in other election
years when I started the tour it was in
late January and Trump was still a
punchline like this will never happen
right at that point they were still I
think a good seven or eight people left
maybe nine and then he became the
candidate and that would that all
happened in the course of the American
part of the tour and this tour had more
people that were less familiar with my
stand-up work than the last couple of
tours and so I had a lot of walkouts on
this tour some quiet some very noisy
disruptive but there were walkouts
concerts this one is paying 100 percent
to me it's the worst tasting hot sauce
it's not the hottest hot sauce but it is
just a bad taste there tickled burnt my
god there are several layers levels of
pain the pain levels are marked with a
percentage of oh Jesus of a pain you
experience I can't believe that's a
selling point so you play the voice of
zero in grand theft auto san andreas
yeah nothing is up Carl apart from my
blood pressure I know that you're a big
fan of Vice City which is kind of how
you were able to work your way into San
Andreas I cornered um his name is Shawn
I camera from Rockstar
yeah I cornered him drunk ed uh I think
it was MX fish one night I was like I'm
a huge fan I love it I'll do anything
I'll work scale whatever you know san
andreas versus Vice City kind of pops up
which do you prefer and why I here's
here's why I slightly favored by City I
thought the extra acting the things that
people said and the and the voices were
better and by City
I love the hey
mr. V that guy [ __ ] kill me all Tyra
Tommy come out of the mansion hey it's
mr. B you know your mission is a wordy
tough I just stopped and you do not
listen nope I stopped I tried to cheat I
could not listen to myself it was so
annoying so annoying don't let him get
away
punish him for his war crime hey I can I
haven't heard it in years but so you're
haunted by your own voice hated it and I
couldn't [ __ ] do it the RC car thing
for the planes impossible it's
ridiculous
and it's the most annoying voice you
could ever imagine accompanying that
smells like victory to bomb beyond
insanity is it what is there such a
thing what is beyond it so let's find
out so this one kind of taste it either
mm-hmm none of them are good from here
on out I saw you post a pic from what
the grit in Athens Georgia would you get
the golden bone yeah I don't like that
one Jesus
I may need a do-rag - it's like a leaky
tap my head sweat going yeah that's
awful
beyond insanity dude I don't even know
what that is
it's inconceivable can't conceive of it
what's beyond insanity I don't know man
you tell me [ __ ] how would you
describe beyond insanity I describe it
as hot habanero peppers relatable smokey
20 members after the brunch based on the
Blessed Mother classical music product
of Kansas
well those do things don't really go
together I thought with all the juice
you have can you ever cut that line at
Franklin's barbecue in Austin nobody can
ever cut that line President Obama I
think is the only one who's ever done it
I never came in and cut in but when the
very first time in which Franklin's
which is astoundingly great absolutely
perfect somebody said Oh David Cross
series would want to come down and and
they have a table in the back and go
kind of behind Franklin's there's like a
little picnic table I never literally
cut in line but we went to the back
table and they said and they was
fantastic they don't do that for
everybody no it was very nice so where
is my wife and I and some friends and
take some folks from Austin I mean it
key exemplary it was the best of the
best holding together yep this is Mad
Dog 357 it used to be our hottest sauce
now it's our second hottest sauce so
great all right
ah so just knowing you and your
sensibilities I think that you'd maybe
be the worst in my job that isn't
creative or isn't what you're doing
what's the worst job you've ever had
I've had lots and lots of nods I hereby
disclaim release and relinquish any and
all claims and actions and lawsuits why
would anybody it's not what's the point
it doesn't taste good no it's unpleasant
right and it's it ruins everything it
touches like chocolate okay let's go all
right worst job I would say actually the
worst job ever had was during the heat
wave in Chicago in the mid-80s where a
bunch of people died and I was in a
warehouse working with terrible people
one time we had to take a truck load it
up this big big truck the guy who was
driving any time we'd be at a light
crosswalk and would yell out to women yo
[ __ ] uh lift up that dress let me see
that mess and then like let me see that
mess and I'm implicated but lift up that
dress let me see that mess yo [ __ ] lift
up that dress let me see that mess yeah
and by proxy your you know guilt by
association I'm just like oh my god it's
awful don't do that what what's up bro
come on he's one of those real bro guys
and that was like like my boss
so you do it man how do you do this is
it how do I often you take these things
weekly so now that I've done so many
yeah I feel like I'm probably
desensitized from just lighting my mouth
on fire once a week and then the other
part of it is I feel like a sense of
responsibility not only for the audience
but for you you're a busy and talented
dude I don't want to let you down either
you know what I mean I don't want to let
you down I don't want to let the people
down there's just a lot of pressure and
when you have that kind of pressure you
can do amazing things I'm doing better
than I expected
certainly stomach wise but matte lips
really catching on the face so this is
Megadeath sauce with liquid rage before
you take the bite you don't have to if
you don't want to but I like to dab the
last wing for the pink pull out I'll let
you do mine
I get nervous doing other people's cuz
I'm like cool I'm not the first person
to ask that Carly Aquilino had me do
hers too not David Cross I won't I'm
just having you do it because I imagine
you're gonna do it less than I would do
boom that already looks scary yeah all
right okay so now before I ask this
question let me just break it down
so of course you put the great device
for you but this thing is so hot crack
the lid on this thing Jesus or maybe I'm
just so strong that I
the tork am i screwing I think it's the
former okay you played the great device
for UK and Arrested Development fans are
kind of like Star Wars fans and are kind
of like Game of Thrones fans where some
of that fan base kind of knows more
about the show oh for sure
then the people who made it and the
people who are in it what I want to do
is we take a bite of this wing and I
want to hit you with some Arrested
Development fan trivia okay and see if
you can answer it with your face on fire
okay okay I feel like you're two out of
three on this okay so I'm gonna say
before okay alright cheers David all
right get to the end now the worst this
series of self-help videos that George
senior stars and and produces from
prison
I don't remember caged wisdom cage was
caged wisdom alright ready this is oh
can we get to our three-year michael
negotiates the licensing rights to this
cartoon character away from joe
oh the the banana the banana grabber
thank you and then if george senior has
to rush out for milk he might
accidentally run someone over and knock
off his arm and that's why you always
leave a note leave no no yeah alright
David yeah you made it through how'd you
do better than you thought you would
worse than you think Evan definitely
better than I thought how does how does
this company make money because it's not
like you're gonna go through a bottle
every month or so a long time a lifetime
yeah Megadeth with liquid exuding the
difference I've had regular Megadeth
sauce didn't care for it when they added
the liquid rage that's what that's what
got me that's what made you across the
via all right David you made it through
the floor is yours let the people know
what you got going on in your life
starting on the 5th of August you can
check out my comedy specials yeah taped
it in April in Austin Texas it's called
making America great again and hopefully
they'll be in the audio release at some
point when I could figure that part out
thanks for coming through David yeah man
you